Ukraine and Russia have reached
agreement on the removal of hundreds of
Ukrainian soldiers from the as of style
steel Works in a Mario pool around 600
members of the so-called as of regiment
have been trapped there for weeks
Ukraine's Deputy defense minister said
the soldiers were being taken by uh
through by Russia through a humanitarian
Corridor for medical treatment in
russian-held territory several buses
carrying the soldiers left the plant on
Monday night now the move means that
Ukraine has now effectively ceded full
control of the city of marupol to Russia
departing in darkness and under Russian
guard the first Ukrainian troops have
left the azov style steel Works after
weeks of fierce resistance
buses brought 53 of the worst injured to
a hospital here in the nearby
russian-controlled town of Novo azovsk
Ukrainian officials said another 211
soldiers had been taken to separatist
territory further north
president zielinski made clear that
getting as of Style's Defenders home was
a priority
we hope to save the lives of our boys
among them are heavily wounded they are
being treated I want to underline
Ukraine needs its Ukrainian Heroes alive
this is our principle
the work continues to bring our boys
home and it requires delicacy and time
it's unclear just how many soldiers are
still left inside the heavily bombarded
as of style complex
but the evacuation seems to indicate
that the long and bitter Siege is
drawing to an end the Ukrainian Army
announced late on Monday that the main
goal now was to save the lives of the
remaining Defenders
earlier I spoke to our correspondent Max
Xander in leviv and I asked him what
more we know about the 260 troops that
have been evacuated from the as of style
steel plant
so that's right and yes from what we
know right now is that more than 260
Defenders a Ukrainian military personnel
were evacuated from the Oz of steel
plant 53 of them are supposed to be in
in their critical condition or supposed
to be heavily wounded and will receive
medical treatment in Russian Health
territory and the remaining roughly 211
are supposed to be transferred and then
later take part in a prisoner swap
needless to say a situation in the aztal
steelworks uh we've heard of it a lot in
the last couple of months as was
incredibly die or so the people who were
fighting they were all in a quite
difficult condition there have been many
calls for their evacuation though not to
Russian territory something that the
Russians would not agree on or did not
agree on in the past so now it seems
that this indicates a change in in
politics there there in the region
actually sending military personnel you
ukrainians into Russian territory and
putting putting them into that situation
but as we heard just now in that report
and the priority now seems to be to save
lives and do whatever it takes
DW correspondent Max Thunder reporting
there from leviv
and we are joined Now by Dr Anton
chekhaftsoff director of the center for
Democratic integrity and a senior fellow
at the free Russia Foundation he joins
us from Vienna welcome to DW Dr
sheghavsov is the evacuation of
Ukrainian soldiers from the asostel
plant a victory for Russia
um well first of all thank you for
having me and I must say no this is not
a victory for the um for for the Russian
Federation because uh the uh The
Defenders of the azov style plant have
totally fulfilled the order of the
higher command of Ukraine
they have drawn uh overwhelming forces
of the Russian Federation and they
defended I think even for a longer
period than anyone could could have
thought uh that they would that they
would be able to to defend the city for
such a long time so it's not a victory
now they have been taken by Russian
soldiers to russian-controlled territory
How likely is it that a prisoner
exchange will happen and that the
evacuees will be brought back to
Ukrainian territory
uh you see uh Ukraine has around a
thousand uh of the Russian prisoners of
war and I think I really hope that the
Russians will not um
[Music]
um uh try to to put their own pows in
danger so uh of course
um The Defenders Of Us of style being
taken to the Russia occupied territories
this is not good news but I do hope that
the the leadership of Ukraine has uh
thought through uh this particular
scenario and has
um ensured that nothing really happens
nothing bad happens to to to to
Ukrainian prisoners of War now and as we
know unfortunately uh sometimes the the
the Russian uh soldiers and officers
actually kill uh Ukrainian pows in
violation of the all humanitarian and
international rules of War I really hope
that doesn't happen now
talk about
these evacuations mean for the direction
of the war and for Ukraine
um we see that Russia is retreating on
many directions uh we saw that several
weeks ago it started the retreat from
the key of region now we're seeing the
retreat of the Russian forces from the
heart attack region from that direction
they will try because uh of course they
are suffering
um of heavy losses
um in in many directions what I what I
think is going to happen now they are
going to fortify their positions in the
jarson and zaporizia oblas so basically
the regions that are attached to the uh
not attached but very close to the NX
Crimea but also they are going to
fortify their positions in the Donetsk
and luhansk oblasts
unfortunately yes mariopal is now are
practically occupied entirely by the by
the Russian Invaders and um of course
unfortunately uh the the war crimes that
were committed by the Russian forces
will have to wait for investigations of
the international of the international
buddies but um I do believe that the the
occupation the total occupation of
marupal
will not uh hold for long all right
we'll have to leave it there Dr Anton
chekovitzov director of the center for
Democratic integrity
uh in Vienna thank you so much
thank you
now Russia accuses members of the azov
Regiment of being neo-nazis some
analysts refute this saying that it may
have been true when the Battalion was
first founded in 2014 but that since
then they have become less radical DW's
fanny fachar has been investigating this
claim and among the people she spoke to
was the sister of one of the fighters
who has been holed up in the as of style
steel works
for Natalya the war in Ukraine has been
a time of intense worry and reflection
she's thinking a lot about her younger
brother these days
this is my brother artem at school when
he was eight or nine
Natalia recalls a very normal childhood
growing up in mikolai in southern
Ukraine I always considered artem to be
a creative person and that he would go
down a more creative path and never
thought he'd become a soldier
but when the war in dombas began in 2014
Natalia says artem changed
he knew that sooner or later the
aggressor will bring War to our country
and he knew that he needed to prepare
Artemis 26 joined the answer regiment a
few years ago it was formed as a
volunteer militia group and later became
part of the National Guard
he still hold up here in the as of style
steel plant the last holdout of
Ukraine's forces in the port city of
mariopol
the regiment released these pictures
displaying the horrible conditions some
of the fighters are in
Putin accuses the unit of being Nazis
he's Justified his invasion by claiming
that Ukraine needs in his words the
nazifying which has drawn a backlash
globally
here in Keith the unit is seen as Heroes
Billboards have sprung up supporting the
soldiers
I am expressing huge gratitude for them
for standing for us for our Ukraine
for Putin as for every Russian every
Ukrainian is radical but we only want to
live on our own and we strive to speak
our own language and every as of soldier
is a Ukrainian
because researches right-wing groups he
says it's correct that the founders of
azov Harbor neo-announced reviews but
insists let's change now all those guys
who were interested in politics more
than in military actions they gone from
the Battalion and regiment after a first
several months of its existing in 2014.
Natalia doesn't want to get into azov's
controversial past she's more worried
for her brother artem
Novato
here he was texting me that he's alive
and that's it he writes very short
messages unfortunately
holding on to science of life and hoping
her brother will return a life